why can I never escape school okay so
you all know you don't know what's even
worse right is that so I was watching
anime on YouTube still this point right
so I remember
cuz I would get I'd go to my anime list
because that's what I have one did right
like you would look at which ones are
high rated and which ones you know for
some reason school daze was like one of
the highest-rated but but it was like it
was like it was like split right between
light it was either a 10 or a 2 yeah and
I thought I'm gonna be in the 10
categories yeah everything I watched so
far [ __ ] la yeah so first off I
already had a bad start watching school
days because I remember watching school
days HQ or something and it was like
like a spin-off it was like 40 minutes
school days HQ to explain is the
original visual novel of school days but
the original visual novel of school days
was basically just a full-on anime yeah
right it was all animated I didn't know
that this is the first time I just found
that out yeah so you can watch you can
watch all of school days HQ on something
like pornhub or next videos which if
you're really just like if you're really
just looking to watch the you know clips
that you're looking for you can just
find it oh and they would have showed
the clips and that I didn't get that far
I got about suits a 40 minute episode
one right and I watched 40 minutes and I
was like this isn't this isn't seem
right am i watching the right thing like
everyone's saying it's good right it's
so funny that you saying like the school
days like mal is either like a 10 or
yeah I know you didn't because going on
here I know what mindset you were in
where you were like every time I'm in
the [ __ ] hood I gotta say why am I
saying this
someone who gave students attend okay
look that sheep right who everyone else
is set at a 10 and he doesn't want to be
that one guy was like I don't think I
have good taste no way I have good taste
I can appreciate it so that's Scott
because for me right Lee school days was
like
it was crap until the last episode
because the last episode I was like
first of all I remember just like
sitting there I'm not gonna say it but
I'm sure there's lots of people
maleic school days for me that ending is
like the most satisfying thing I'd ever
seen it okay okay I will give you that
it was satisfying but then I remembered
like I just sat through 11 of the most
boring [ __ ] in my life yeah and I don't
think this is a big enough to redeem it
like the first the first 11 episodes was
just like I think I need anger
management right yeah oh my god I hate
the main character so my whole and then
I gone and then he's like the [ __ ]
orgasm you gotta episode 12 where what
happened happens and you're like oh yeah
that ending for me made it it in no I
specifically remember I'm like I'm glad
I went through those 11 episodes going
no that's satisfying that's [ __ ]
that is bullet that's recency bias right
cuz you're you're basing your review of
how it ended not the [ __ ] the
absolute [ __ ] truck that you were till
like a shovel okay nobody yet but he's
the thing right like i I've said this so
many times in videos but like the ending
for me is so [ __ ] important because
like I have good that goldfish brain but
iTunes everything else
no I just like them because they may
want to like for me was amazing first 10
episodes and the ending was just the
most garbage [ __ ] II like okay we
ran out of budget ending that I've ever
seen that it just completely wrong II
class doesn't mean it's a one I mean I
[Applause]
get devil in the Wonderland the anime
yeah like a five what no no it's better
than a five because then I read the
manga never monk is infinitely better
you think so yeah I thought whether
because the manga actually ends it's
better than the [ __ ] anime I guess I
am a reading Deadman Wonderland and I
kind of liked what it did a little bit
but the ending I wasn't too big with fan
over them all right but I excited even
if it was like a mediocre ending right
ending at least I got an okay ending
whereas the anime just left me wanting
more and I'm like don't [ __ ] tease me
like that after ten amazing episodes
would you rather a show that has like
ten amazing episodes with with no ending
or 24 episodes with 10 amazing episodes
and it starts to go kind of man the
endings a little questionable
the first braggers when we got with dead
man there yeah I remember your angers
and that's why I but but like oh I'm
trying I'm just trying to like wrap my
head around how you could justify like
I've just been sitting here for like the
past few minutes having a [ __ ] mental
myself let me let me rephrase let me
rephrase okay I had so many opinion
changes on the ending to school days
like sorry okay so what would you give
school days now then now I would give it
a six
no no I had a face I had a face where
I'm like is this ending genius or is it
the worst garbage if I if I like you
know if I make a character that is so
[ __ ] abhorrent and then I kill him
off oh yeah he's not even a good
character like there's not a good
character exactly the reason why the
ending it's satisfying but it's just so
[ __ ] surface level you know I'll and
I wouldn't watch it again he he like
this protagonist it's the one that we
follow he made this character dog [ __ ]
on purpose but then there's also a
little bits where he tries to make you
like the guy and that's the words right
and that's what I [ __ ] hate like no
don't truly be sympathize with this con
he's had like a threesome in like class
three be like what the [ __ ] you just had
like he's especially a dad that's the
one character development that uh what
the folks Makoto had that's knows his
name
Makoto valued I complete because he's so
[ __ ] plans I couldn't even remember
his [ __ ] I can't remember any of the
character no I love the one derivative
of Makoto hat is like he started out as
this like absolute synthase kya to these
most like the Giga chat and I'm the
episode for me that made me like had to
light pause and go like it was like the
wind when they want one of the have like
a threesome I like post it and I was
like chop them up there
chop the [ __ ] mutt there no it was so
like like it was literally a porn plot
how it happened is a [ __ ] born it was
schooldays hate you there's a pond
that's the worst thing about it right is
they try and sell you that it's not a
port
and then they hit you with the in front
of my salad applause and you're like no
this isn't what I want like and the fact
that people on mal had the [ __ ] balls
to be like this is an artistic
masterpiece of our generation is
absolute genius you guys the timing is
impeccable it's like no it's like it's
like yeah okay if my dog got rabies and
I watched it die her for three hours
yeah I'd probably see it put down B
would be satisfying right because it's
just suffering that's what that anime
was he was just suffering I [ __ ]
hated it and the fact that I had to then
watch 40 minutes of a let's play or
whatever the [ __ ] it was the first thing
I didn't watch that and the worst part
was is that imagine okay before you
could even start the dog [ __ ] power that
is the [ __ ] school days you had to
watch 40 minutes of the same thing
before you started the same thing again
so I remember watching the first episode
already bored out of my mind because I'd
seen this [ __ ] before in it in a
slightly different way and I was like
okay I hate school school day sucks [ __ ]